hello everyone i hope you're all having
an excellent sunday because we have a
really an incredible game between two
engines it's a game between stockfish
and komodo uh from the tcec
that's the top chess engine competition
and it is uh not often i will show a
game between two engines so okay i did
enjoy that uh alpha zero versus
stockfish match and also
uh i will show a lilac chess zero game
now and then uh
just uh you know see what progress leela
has made
but it is very rare that i will show a
game between two engines mostly because
uh
those games are really boring and last
like a hundred
or 200 or or more moves and it's
not not something we can use to to
improve or
or to to even enjoy but this game it
features a very old opening one of the
oldest openings
in chess and it's very interesting uh
how both stockfish and komo
komodo treat this opening uh it comes as
a suggestion
from a user on twitter named lorianno
there you can see uh
below this uh spanish version of chess24
tweet he tagged me there
and uh i'm really thankful for that as
uh
you know some people don't allow tagging
on twitter i i really don't mind because
often people will tag me and you know
bring my attention to a very nice game
such as this one
so uh thank you to chess24 and also mr
loriano or mrs
as i don't know uh for bringing this
game to my attention
now without further ado let's check out
this very nice game uh stockfish
rated some uh 3519 plays e4
uh we have e5 by komodo uh knight to f3
knight to c6 bishop to c4 and knight to
f6 so the two nice defenses on the board
uh if you br you know grab any book on
chess openings
most likely if it's about open games you
will
have the two knights defense uh in in
there uh
knight to g5 this is the night attack
one of the oldest and the trickiest
attacks uh
in chess altogether uh going immediately
after this
f7 pawn and it's not all that clear how
to
uh how to defend the f7 pawn if if
you're
explaining how to play chess to a
beginner this is actually one of the
best
attacks you can show them to really
understand how to
how to attack and defend in chess uh
well there are
several ways you can go about this you
can go for some bishop to c5 like the
traxler counter attack but we're not
gonna go into that now
d5 is the main move uh and it's a move
that
has been played for over a hundred years
uh he captures on d5 and not
knight to a5 uh if you accept this pawn
uh
knight captures on d5 then you have to
go into knight captures on f7 this is
the fried liver attack
i'm sure you've you've seen it at least
somewhere
after king captures queen to f3 check
now you have a double attack against the
knight on d5 also the knight cannot
block because it's pinned from the
bishop
you would have to go with king to e6 to
block your
uh to help out with the defense of the
knight
or move the king back and then just
suffer a loss of a pawn or if you're
playing against a really bad opponent
uh maybe even king to j8 will be played
and then you can deliver a swift
checkmate with
the bishop after bishop to e6 this will
be checkmate as the king has nowhere to
go
uh but as this is a game between two
very strong engines
knight to a5 of course this is nothing
new a move has been played
plenty of times by both beginners and
grand masters
uh we have bishop to b5 with check c6
pawn captures on c6 spawn captures on c6
and now bishop to e2
we have h6 and now comes knight to h3
it's interesting knight to f3 can also
be played then you go into this
e4 variation but also very playable
but the knight to h3 is actually a move
stein is prepared for his uh
match against uh mikhail chigorin and
it's very interesting uh this is a
position
uh that was on the board uh more than
once uh
in uh chigon versus steinitz match in
1892 so
over 125 years ago and this is why chess
is uh
very interesting and i believe it will
always be interesting
uh here uh stein's uh jiggling played
bishop to c5 on
numerous occasions against the chigo and
played this against stein it's
on numerous occasions in their match and
some of the games he won some of the
games he lost
but uh here uh komodo goes for g5 but
it's very interesting
this is quite a mess on the board and if
today's engines
that rate themselves some 3 500
uh have this exact same position uh that
uh
after move 10 uh that uh steinis and
chigo and had on the board 125 years ago
then really those old masters really
knew what they were doing
but okay g5 this is nothing new has been
played plenty of times by grand masters
capturing on h3 doesn't really give you
anything you just
waste your bishop pair and after white
develops uh his forces he will have a
bishop pair and it's a very much open
game and the white will have an
advantage
something stein is also new uh some
hundred and twenty-five years ago and
that's why chigodin never actually
captured this night with the bishop
uh so uh g5 here by comodo
and knight to c3 stockfish continues to
develop uh and
here is a new move a move that was never
played at least in human chess here
bishop to g7 was played bishop to e6 was
played rook to b8 was played
a lot of developing moves by human
players but here uh komodo plays a move
that was not played here
ever it's knight to b7 so and amu with
the knight back
uh and we'll see what's what his idea is
uh knights the g1 are preparing to
remain over the knight
not allowing the g4 to come with tempo
uh bishop to c5
now developing a bishop and now comes
king to f1
uh if you start with the d3 immediately
then you have to go into this queen to
b6
comes with an attack against the f2 pawn
this will come with check
so now you'll have to move the king and
after bishop captures knight to a4 you
will attack the queen queen to a5
captures captures and uh well obviously
it's not all that great as
it was not played but okay bishop to c5
uh king to f1 and now comes the bishop
to e6 i will just
try and make sense of most of the moves
as i really don't have the software or
the hardware
to that to really go into why a 3500
engine played what he did
uh but okay d3 uh we have queen to c7
preparing to castle queenside
uh rook to b1 and now castle's queen
side and now comes the queen to e1
uh most likely queen to one because if
uh
b4 immediately attacking the bishop the
bishop will come to d4
attacking the undefended knight and then
you will have to play queen to e1 either
way
so perhaps better queen to e1
immediately and then
you'll see if you really want to play b4
uh bishop to b6
not allowing this b4 to come with tempo
and now b4
uh knights to d6 we have knights to a4
uh
going for that very strong bishop on b6
and rook hd8
uh centralizing uh the rooks uh bishop
to b2
attacking the e5 pawn and now comes the
bishop to f5
and now the rook is guarding the e5 pawn
rook to d1
we have bishop to d4 attacking the
bishop and now c3 forcing the bishop
back and only now will knight capture it
knight captures on b6 we have a captures
on b6 and now
c4 so uh white definitely has some nice
expansion on the queen side a4 is coming
at some point
uh but the one thing you can notice is
that all of black's pieces are
well perhaps not ideally placed but they
are very much developed and
they are occupying some very nice
squares while uh
stockfish's pieces are really stuck on
the
on the bottom rank uh the light square
bishop isn't really doing all that much
and okay the dark square bishop is a
pretty decent piece but still
it's not at all clear what what he's
doing but okay
rook to d7 preparing either to double up
on the e file or the d
file and now comes queen to c3
now uh attacking the e5 pawn if rook is
doubled here then of course the pawn can
be captured and also not
allowing e4 as now the knight on f6
would be hanging
so it's very interesting if you put it
this position on on
for for example your engine or something
uh moves like a rook d
e seven will be a suggestion bishop to
g4 will be a suggestion offering a trade
of bishops
uh but the move uh comodo played in this
position is basically the reason
why we're showing this game and how uh
everything
you know blows up in this position uh
the move commodore
played and if you want you're more than
welcome to pause the video here and you
know
try and figure out what he played and
what he played you know those are two
different things
anyone can guess what he played but it's
a different story why he played it
uh but okay if you have a pause the
video and uh found the move
congratulations you really
are a very creative player on a sunday
and for those of you who want to enjoy
the show the move played was
e4 and it seems like this was impossible
because the knight on f6
was undefended uh but it seems like it
is
uh so what's the idea here to find out
it's best to capture the knight and ask
questions later so okay queen captures
an f6 this was played in the game
and now comes e captures on d3 so okay
now we see that
for the price of this very nice knight
on f6 black
already has a pass pawn on d3 so white
has to do something as
his bishop on e2 is under attack uh we
have bishop to f3 but
we also have to figure out what happens
if bishop captures on
on d3 uh then of course the bishop
captures rook captures and now comes
knight captures on c4 opening up a
discovered attack from this
rook uh to the rook on d3 and also
notice that this rook is covering the
entire e
file so if this rook would move uh
anywhere from the d
file uh moves like knights to d2 would
be checkmate
uh so after rook captures queen captures
uh you would have
something like uh g3 because you have to
prevent
either queen to d1 will be checkmate or
knights to d2 will be checkmate
uh but now after g3 queen to d5 will win
you the game
as there is no way to protect the rook
knight f3 loses to g4 simply attacking
the knight
and if you try f3 you're getting
checkmated after queen d1
king moves uh knight checks king moves
and now queen to f1
will be checkmate as the knight is
covering both the g2 and the g4
on the other hand uh instead after this
knight captures on c4 if you don't trade
the rooks if you try something like
queen to f5 to simply pin the rook and
attack it
then knight captures on b2 is more than
enough rook captures queen captures
queen captures king captures
and here the material on the board would
be equal but
with uh white king so inactive and all
of white's pieces undeveloped
black would be very quick to to grab
all of the pawns on the queen side and
win the game easily
so after this e captures on d3 you
cannot capture
on d3 so bishop to f3 was played
which is very interesting because of the
next few moves
black played rook to e7 attacking the
queen we have queen to d4
and now comes knight the e8 attacking
the queen as this opened up a discovered
attack from the rook to the queen queen
to c3 and
now g4 trapping the bishop so if we look
at it this way the sacrifice of the
knight and f6 wasn't really a sacrifice
if black knew that he would win the
bishop
back which uh brings us to the next
question and we have to go back a few
moves
if white is obviously a very strong
engine rated 3500
why would he play bishop to f3 instead
of bishop to h5 so perhaps if the bishop
is on h5
uh black will not be able to trap it
after this sequence with
the move g4 uh but uh if we check out
the same idea
rook to e6 uh queen to here now comes
knight back
queen has to move now comes knight to f6
uh it comes
with an attack on the bishop the bishop
is undefended you have to move it and
then g4 traps it again
uh or you could argue that g4 perhaps
could save you the bishop here but
then you get bishop to e4 attacking the
rook
and after f3 knight captures on h5 pawn
captures and now after g4
uh you cannot capture because you lose
the rook here and if you capture the
bishop here then queen to f4
and you're getting checkmated if kingi
won then rook captures here
and knight e2 rook captures on e2 will
be checkmate and if you don't go
uh to e1 with the king if you go to g2
then you get the queen captures on e4
uh king g3 queen captures on h1 white is
falling apart here
and also a very interesting idea after
bishop to h5 uh perhaps
white didn't go for this uh because
after
rookie six attacking the queen queen
before now black doesn't even have to go
back with the knight like we've just
shown he can even go
knight to e4 and then uh black can
draw the game by force after the queen
moves let's say with check you attack
the queen queen goes back
now comes queen to f4 you threaten
checkmate on f2
after white defends it now you get
knight captures on f2
king captures and queen e3 check king
moves queen of fortune king moves queen
e3 check king moves and so on and so on
a draw by threefold repetition
uh so uh that's why most likely
stockfish played bishop to f3
not uh not because uh he was uh
well for the lack of a better word
afraid to play bishop to h5
and trying to save the piece but because
he wants to win this game so
apparently bishop to f3 is stockfish's
attempt to win the game
so let's see uh how how it continued uh
rook to e6
we already saw this queen today for
knight attacks well rook attacks queen
as it's a discovered attack queen moves
and now g4
uh attacking the bishop h3 and now black
wins the piece back
knight captures on f3 and now comes the
bishop to e4
we have bishop to c1 and now c5
capturing the knight on f3 isn't uh
great
right now but it is something white will
have to watch out for
first black improves the position of his
queen uh we have c5
uh pawn captures on c5 and queen
captures on c5 and
now uh b5 is a terrible threat as white
will not be able to capture the queen
and c3 is unguarded
but also you cannot allow bishop
captures on f3 for example if you play
a4 and prevent this
then bishop captures on f3 will win you
the game after g
captures and queen to f5 uh the rook is
controlling the entire e file rook can
come to g6 and also control the g
file uh the queen will capture on on f3
attacking the rook on d1 attacking the
rook on h1
so whatever white plays let's say g2
then rook to g6
pushes the king back uh queen captures
threatens checkmate and g2 rogue blocks
captures and
after a couple of checks you will simply
play rook to e7
bring the other rook over to e2 and win
the game easily
so after queen to c5 uh there is no time
to prevent
the pawn push with a4 you have to
prevent this knife from being captured
so knight to e1
but now comes the b5 you cannot capture
as we already mentioned the queen is
unguarded
uh bishop to e3 attacking the queen and
now queen captures on c4
uh white cannot allow captures captures
as the two connected past pawns would be
too much for white to handle so after
queen captures on c4
uh queen to d2 not allowing the trade
queen to d5
uh pressuring the g2 pawn uh and now
comes queen to c3
rook to c6 forcing the queen back queen
to b3 and now comes
knight to c7 uh defending the queen on
d5
and again you don't want to allow this
queen trait so white moves back queen to
b2
uh and now comes queen to c4 and
excellent square for black's queen
because
white will never be able to to trade
queens here on this square
uh king the g1 as the threat uh
before this was uh this check with the
d2
uh so king the g1 and now knight to d5
we have king to h2 and down knight
captures on e3 uh
f captures on e3 and now f5
uh and okay rook to g1 uh white did
manage to
activate his other rook uh but now comes
queen to a4 attacking the rook on a on
d1
uh queen to a1 defending the rook and
now king to b7
improving the position of the king we
have a3 and now comes
rook to g6 and now black wants to double
up on the g
file uh queen to c1 and now comes rook
to d8
uh a waiting move uh that basically puts
white in sukhuang
uh white queen can't really move as she
has to keep an eye
on the eighth re pawn uh and also the
rook on d1 you can't really move uh
the knight ended the rook as the the the
black bishop and rook are attacking the
g2 pawn
uh there's really no point in moving any
of the pawns you can't
no point in really moving the king
whatsoever uh so it's it's a very hard
position for white and it's very
interesting if you try something like
rook to d2 which seems like
a useful move you know adding another
defender here
then white has this very and black has
this very annoying queen to c4 that will
force a queen trade
uh the queen is under attack and also
undefended you have to play knight to f3
to defend
the queen and now after bishop captures
spawn captures
now you can double up on the g file and
here after rook to f1 avoiding the trade
f4 now white is out of any useful moves
you will have to capture capture and
then
doesn't matter you will give up the df
or pawn but the double the
past pawns will be enough to win this uh
so after rook to d8 this very nice
waiting move by komodo
queen to d2 was played giving up the a3
pawn uh
so komodo snatches it and now comes rook
to f1
uh rook to c6 uh preparing uh some very
nasty ideas
uh we have a queen to f2 and now comes
rook to g8 uh g3 and now rook back to c
c8 as the g file is now closed uh we
have
h4 and now comes rook to c2 finally uh
comodo finds a way how to infiltrate you
have to capture it as your queen
and king are uh well on the same
file as this rook knight captures on c2
was played rook captures on c2 attacking
the queen and king we have rook to d2
blocking
and here komodo played queen to c3 and
it was in this position that
stockfish resigned the game another just
any stockfish
uh a 3519 raided stockfish
uh why did uh the stockfish resign well
if
captures rook then pawn captures the
threat is pawn to c
pawn to c1 will bring another queen into
the game and if you block this
then b4 you will of course push your
other pawn to victory
uh queen to f1 with the threat of queen
to b5 check
doesn't really do anything as after the
king moves there are no more checks the
queen is covering
a5 c5 and there are no other
other squares for you to check and also
e5
so yeah oh and of course if you don't do
anything uh after
this queen to c3 if you just move the
rook rook after d1 then b4
simply continue pushing your past pawn
and you will win this game easily
so like i said it's not very often that
i will show a game between two engines
especially
such high rated engines as you know it
will be very hard to analyze such a game
uh but i feel that this game uh between
stockfish and komodo from the tcec
uh which really showed us how the old
masters played at uh for example that uh
schneids versus chigo in game uh where
after knight to h3 the move stein it's
invented
uh this knights the b7 was played so
perhaps if you if you play
you know this uh against the two knights
defense
and you enter this position uh you'll
know that
it's okay to go knight to b7 and that it
can be a very useful move
so yeah uh that's basically it
i would like to thank uh stefan green
tony kotzenturk danny mccullough uh
christian boomer and uh cnn mclugan for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching
and i will see you soon hopefully with
some more interesting content
the fisher series is over um
but we will start a vote on the next
series very soon so thank you all and
i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of the sunday